einen wunderschönen guten Tag Hall mein
Name tut mir leid ich ich hasse es
unpünktlich zu aber es ist doch kaum
oder wo sind wir hier wir sind mit
navigationssystemergefahren wir sind in
einer der schönsten Straßen ja gerade
nicht jetzt ist gerade gesperrt des
brenzlauer Bergs ein Teil meiner neuen
Heimat wie lange schon hier seit halben
Jahr und alles sensationell alles super
und da drüben ist der sensationellste
Eis
eismädchen ganz toll gut dann machen wir
das Interview ganz schnell und dann
gehen wir dannessen abut
gerne ja wie ist die Lage die Lage
aufrecht stabil vertikal ja gut
eigentlich freudig erregt hat das mit
dem Wohnortwechsel zu tun wo haben Sie
eigentlich vorher gewohnen ich habe
davor ganz kurz in München noch gelebt
und davor wieder in Konstanz wo ich
eigentlich herkomme und da vor 10 Jahr
in München und da vor 18 Jahren Konstanz
so und jetzt Berlin ist äh ich sag mal
der Höhepunkt ja ich hätte nie gedacht
dass ich jemals in Berlin also ich glaub
in meinen Überlegung habe ich glaub ich
alle Städte durchgespielt und Berlin war
für mich das absolute no Goo zu groß zu
laut zu heftig so und jetzt bin ich
durch mehrere Umstände hier gelandet und
habe es Gefühl dass ich zum ersten Mal
angekommen bin was sind das für Umstände
äh private in erster Linie genau das
heißt Freundin äh ja also Wechsel
Wechsel Wechsel Aufbruch und da ist
Berlin ja ein tolles Forum dafür und was
hat sie dann überzeugt dass Berlin doch
anders ist als erst gedacht
dadurch dass es so groß ist wird der
eigene Kosmos total klein man bleibt in
seiner eigenen Straße ich wusste auch
nicht was die Leute meinten mit mein
Kids so jetzt weiß ich das ist so eine
Straße man hat alles man lernt plötzlich
viel schneller Leute kennen als in der
Kleinstadt z.B
m ähm wahrscheinlich weil alle Leute
hier so viel Angst haben dass sich
schneller zusammenrotten als in der
Kleinstadt wo jeder so sein Garten hat
und sein Häuschen und und sein sein sein
Teil und hier ist alles kleiner ich
kenne irre viel Leute schon
hier gibt's wahsinnig viel Künstler hier
ist vor allem so wahnsinnig friedfertig
was mir so gut gefällt weil es hier irre
viele Kinder gibt keiner will Stress
weil jeder hat irgendwie ein Kind an der
Hand mindestens eins ich glaube sogar
wenn du hier kein Kind hast
wirst du gemobbt ich ich kenne sogar
Leute die sich schon so kinderwegen
kaufen und Hausflur stellen obwohl sie
gar kein eigenes Kind haben nur weil sie
Angst vom Nachbaren aber sie haben ein
Kind ich hab ein Kind und das kommt ab
und zu auch mal hierher oder wie wie
gehen fahren sie zu ihm zu meinem Kind
ja oder wir wohnen alle in einer Straße
sie wohnen alle in einer Straße ja so
fast also nur mal zur Klarstellung sie
sind nicht mit der Mutter sind sie
getrennt und aber sie fahren dann wie
alt ist das viinhalb viinhalb also
Kinderwagen fahren sie nicht mehr aber
sie gehen mit ihm durch die Straße und
Kindergarten ist wahrscheinlich um die
Ecke genau genau gut also sie werden
nicht gemobt nein ist es denn so ähm
dass Berlin die Menschen vielleicht
verändert ich glaube in Berlin ist alles
möglich in Berlin kannst du alles machen
und ich glaube das öffnet auch den
eigenen Geist und da deswegen verändert
man sich vielleicht auch ein bisschen ja
man wird vielleicht individueller man
traut sich M Charakterzüge mehr
auszuleben die man vielleicht in ein
anderen Stadt oder in ein kleineren
Stadt oder in ein klein geistigeren
Stadt sich nicht unbedingt erlaubt
irgendwie auszuleben vielleicht das ich
wollte jemand vorstellen kurz und ich
bin so begeistert davon bin ich z.
begeistert weil ich
weil ich gestern die Tonprobe gekriegt
hab die erste und zwar das hier das ist
das ist pdy pdy ist der kleine Pirat und
das sind ist eine junge Firma die ist
super Power tonses heißen die und die
machen einen Animationsfilm ein 3D
Animationsfilm und Hörspiele und alles
mögliche und das ist pdy und bei pdy
sprechen ganz berühmte Leute mit also
die Namen werden Ihnen wahrscheinlich
nicht so wahnsinnig viel sagen aber die
Stimmen also es ist äh äh badesal
spricht damit elpino Stimme
schwarznecker Stimme spongeb Stimme und
pdy bin ich mhm und das kommt am 16.09
überall kann man es dann kaufen beim
Löber Audio Verlag in jeder Buch wollte
ich noch mal ganz kurz ih vorstellen
weil ich das wirklich ganz toll finde so
das ist ganz lustig weil da geht's darum
dass er ein Komplex hat weil er zu klein
ist und immer wenn dem kleinen pdy dem
kleinen Pirat gesagt hat du bist ja so
klein ich nehme Dich nicht ernst äh
dann dreht er total durch und das
vielleicht das ist mir eingefallen weil
sie weil wir vorhin über komplexe
Sprachen vielleicht also nicht dass
meine Größe jetzt unbedingt komplex ist
aber das ist auch z.B einer der
Aufmerksamkeit braucht sie haben viele
offene Fragen ich habe viele offene
Fragen ja die Sie regelmäßig suchen ich
ich ich glaube also ich bin jetzt 32 ich
habe ja noch ein bisschen ne und ich
glaube das glaube sicherlich einer der
großen Themen noch in meinem Leben wird
sein wird ich weiß aber noch nicht in
welche Richtung das gehen wird also ich
weiß nur dass es das äh danke schön dass
es alles eine große Anziehungskraft hat
ich kann kaum an der Kirche vorbeigehen
ohne nicht reinzugehen äh ohne
reinzugehen ja
ich ich halte mich wahnsinnig gerne
Kirchen auf ich zünde Kerzen an aber ich
bin mir nicht sicher warum ich das tue
ähm ich glaube nicht
wirklich an Gott aber ich bete ähm ähm
ich glaube an Jesus Christus aber bin
trotzdem gleichzeitig offen für jede
andere Form der Religion und
interessiere mich dafür und informiere
mich
ich weiß also und ich es hat sicherlich
auch was mit meinem Beruf zu tun und
also mein Onkel hat bevorer parer wurde
selber gespielt mein Opa war ein sehr
christlicher Mensch
der auch im Untergrund gearbeitet hat es
ist einfach ein spannendes und irgendein
zentral verankertes Thema in mir aber
ich bin dem noch nicht auf die Schliche
gekommen aber es ist ja schön ähm diese
offenen Fragen noch im Leben zu haben
ähm ich glaube die also diese diese
vielen Fragen die ich habe die rühren
einfach aus dem ich ich also ich
konfrontiere mich halt sehr mit mir
selbst und und bin sehr
selbstreflektierend was das Leben nicht
einfacher macht aber ähm so bin ich ist
denn da eine schon von beantwortet
worden viele ja ja wann passiert sowas
ähm viele Fragen sind beantwortet worden
als ich Vater wurde
ähm war aber auch eine Krise in meinem
Leben also war nicht nur toll also es
war also wenn ich mal so eine Krise
hatte dann ist es als ich Vater wurde
weil ich nur für diesen Beruf gelebt
hate und eben als Jugendlicher immer nur
Theater Theater Theater Theater immer
diese Scheinwelt was will ich sein was
möchte ich sein wo will ich hin und
plötzlich kommt ein Kind und plötzlich
muss ich mich fragen wer bin ich
eigentlich was möchte ich
eigentlich den geben was möchte wie bin
ich eigentlich drauf ja was möchte ich
weitergeben so und da dachte ich wow ich
habe mich in den letzten Jahren echt
wenig mit mir selbst beschäftigt und
immer nur damit beschäftigt wie ich denn
gerne wäre aber zu wenig damit
beschäftigt wie ich eigentlich bin und
das war es war das war das war schon ech
ein Moment und durch dieses Kind bin ich
als
Mensch Welten gewachsen und zu mir
gekommen noch lange nicht angekommen und
das wird noch einige Kinder dauern bis
ich da bis ich bei mir bin aberot sehr
teuer g
aber trotzdem klingt jetzt ein bisschen
platt mehr sein als
Schein das war ich
ja also jetzt mehr sein ich ja also ich
bin mehr bei mir ja als früher aber das
ist glaube ich auch natürlich ist es
auch eine Altersfrage W Ende 20 wenn
wenn mein Vater ich Brut ich bin mit 27
Vater geworden ist jetzt nicht so jung
oder so
äh und ich glaube das ist eh eine Zeit
wo man sich plötzlich mit Dingen
beschäftigt mit seinen eigenen Eltern
mit seiner eigenen Kindheit eben also
man sieht das Kind man sieht wie das
Spiel man sieht das Kind die Welt
entdecken und
ist total
gebannt mit was für einer Naivität Z ein
Kind an Dinge rangeht und welche
Naivität wir schon verloren haben oder
ähm natürlich ist es
hausfrauenpsychologie was ich jetzt
gerade er zähle aber es ist verdammt
normal wahr also
mir ging oder geht immer noch oder uns
geht echt wahnsinnig viel durch die
Lappen weil wir einfach so wahnsinnig
viele Dinge als gegeben betrachten und
das ist schon spannend also meine
Tochter ist einer meiner größten Lehrer
also sie bringt mir vor allem bei also
sie zeigt mir durch ihre allein durch
ihre Präsenz was wichtig ist im Leben es
ist nicht wichtig ob ich die Rolle
wirklich spiele es ist nicht richtig
wichtig ob ich die bekomme es ist es ist
nicht wichtig nächstes Jahr den
Deutschen Fernsehpreis zu haben äh ist
nicht wichtig wichtig
ist da zu sein und
eben mit dieser Tochter oder mit diesen
lieben zusammen zu sein so einfach oder
so blöd oder so unprofessionell oder
unschauspielerisch das klingt aber ich
glaube das ist das eigentliche Ziel wo
wir auch hin wollen als Schauspieler wir
vielleicht auch ja vielleicht hätten wir
weniger komplexe wenn wir oder weniger
den Drang irgendwie die Welt zu erobern
und präsent zu sein und von gesehen zu
werden wenn wir uns mal auf das
Wesentliche um uns herum konzentrieren
oh mein Gott werden die Kollegen mich
hassen für dieses neunmal kluge
geschwetz hier aber es ist wahr es ist
einfach wahr